hi I'm Jerry Steiner with Monsanto in
st. Louis Missouri and a member of the
new vision for agriculture project board
I am really excited about the web launch
today of the new vision for agriculture
the central idea is that we can meet
this huge challenge of near doubling of
food demand by 2050 by putting the
farmer at the center of our thinking and
more importantly our action oughta
borrow a court that I heard today from
Josette Sheeran head of the World Food
Program and it's basically that this
problem is I like to opening a bike lock
you have to align eight tumblers to open
that lock and anything less and the lock
remains closed and in this case the
closed is not needing this challenge of
meeting that food demand doing it an
environmentally sustainable manner and
doing it also in an economically
sustainable manner both for the consumer
and for the farmer I believe we all have
our fingers on one of those toenails and
if we do our part to turn the tumbler in
the right place we're going to be able
to unlock this entire problem and you
know for some that tumblr is on reducing
waste for some it's on the policy to get
investment that is necessary for others
it might be more transparent markets for
our for example it's about better seeds
that produce more and use resources more
wisely but if we all work together we're
going to unlock the entrepreneurial
spirit of farmers and they're going to
meet that demand